Speaker 1: Mypillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell,
known colloquially as Pillow, almost like Cher
or Madonna or Kanye, maybe for a better example.
He is now running for chairman of the Republican
National Committee. This is absolutely the best.
This guy is increasingly cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs,
and I can think of no more logical choice
to run such a nutty party than Mike Pillow.
Here he is on Real America's Voice. We're still
trying to figure out what that is explaining.
Speaker 4: He's running this year is true
is 100% all in. I've seen a big aunt. She's
one of the most important organizations in our
country and is sinking. The ship is going down.
And it needs you know, it needs a leader and it
needs a business leader. It needs someone that
knows how to fix things.
Speaker 1: By the way.
Can we be done with? We need a business person to
lead the country. Here they are, the other place.
Prior to Trump, we really didn't have any examples
of business people making good presidents.
We now have had a businessperson president, one of
the worst disasters that I can remember. And now
they want to do it again in another position. I
mean, listen, if you want to ruin your party with
that, go for it's not making too much sense to me.
Speaker 4: How to be proactive in moving forward
with a change in footprints. Our foot, the
footprint of our country has drastically
changed. It's when you're all over the board.
Things are things that you thought that you
could always count on. You can't count on anymore.
You can't, you know. And so, no, this is 100% I
need. And believe me, people came to me. I'm
sure it sparked this. These were big donors.
And when the big donors are going to leave. When
the RNC, when you have all its own members going,
hey, we want to hear their donors aren't given
and and your and your party is going to crumble
and it's already up here. If they don't have a
plan of something different coming in a different
endpoint, you're going to get the same output.
Steve. So I say to that you want you want to
make this you want to succeed. You get you get me
elected to the all these states where, you know,
one of those hundred and 68 people that I'm
going to call each and every one of them.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay, so listen, pillow's
running. Is this just what Republicans need?
Is he, in a sense, the most logical choice? I hope
that this happens. I think it would be an absolute
disaster for the Republican Party. One of the I am
not a fan in any way of Ron Rona. Ronna McDaniel.
Ronna McDaniel. But at least she was from the
wing. That sometimes would realize, hey, you know,
it's probably not great for us for Trump to
come to Georgia to help Herschel Walker. He's
probably doing more damage than than helping
at this point in time. She had some connection
to reality in terms of MAGA, even if I find
her politics completely deplorable. Pillow
is a guy who will go. What we need is Trump.
We need Trump everywhere. We need lawsuits
everywhere. We need to talk about how we
won every election that we actually lost,
and we know how that turned out for them in
2022. So I welcome Mike Pillow running here.